no dollars you notice in Las Vegas were
in good hands Jeff Bohr and bianna
golodryga are here we're still coming to
grips with that devastating day
yesterday and the newspapers all around
the country when the front pages really
tell the story the mass shooting in Las
Vegas is being described this morning
like a war zone
the numbers are creating staggering
staggering headlines 59 people were
killed 527 injured on Sunday night it
was the deadliest attack in the US since
9/11 the country music fans who became
victims describe an unimaginable ambush
Norah O'Donnell is near the scene
outside the Mandalay Bay Resort and
Casino with new details of the victims
and the investigation nor a good morning
hey good morning to all of you that's
right this Massacre unimaginable and as
the city it's still stunned I get in
last night it's been more than 24 hours
after the attack but still everyone
trying to come to grips with what
happened we're also hearing
extraordinary accounts of courage and
heroism by many of the 22,000 people who
were targeted at that Country Music
Festival behind the numbers are the
faces and the stories of those who were
killed on Sunday night we now know some
of their names this morning identified
victims reportedly range in age from 20
to 57 one mother and grandmother died in
the arms of her husband of 32 years we
also know more about the suspect 64 year
old Steven paddock who brought the 23
guns and thousands of rounds of
ammunition into his suite at Mandalay
Bay police found 19 more weapons in his
home now that is a total of 42 guns and
we're learning new details of his sniper
style attack from the 32nd floor and the
response from concert goers who were
caught in a horrifying barrage of
gunfire below we're gonna begin with
John Blackstone was who is here in Las
Vegas when the shooting
happened John good morning good morning
well the alleged gunman Steven paddock
checked into the Mandalay Bay Hotel on
Thursday law enforcement officials tell
CBS News over the next three days he was
able to bring in bags full of weapons
and ammunition into his suite building
his deadly arsenal as a registered hotel
guests as panic swept through the crowd
of more than 22,000 country music fans
six police officers rushed across the
street to the Mandalay Bay with the help
of hotel security they located gunman
Steven Craig paddock inside a suite on
the 32nd floor at around 10:20 4 p.m.
shooting through windows he'd smashed
with a hammer I know that he shot the
one security guard up on the 32nd floor
but I don't know if he continued to
shoot after that or not the guard
survived and about an hour later the
SWAT team stormed the room freeze freeze
freeze you have one suspect down inside
the room
police believe padic killed himself this
is the same hotel building the gunman
was in on Sunday night just in the next
wing but this is about the same view he
had in the darkness on Sunday night
clearly he's a long way away here but
it's a clear line of sight and with the
high-powered weapons he had he was able
to do tremendous damage I seriously
thought he was next door army veteran
Chris Bethel was just two floors below
the gunman when the shooting began the
walls and the windows were vibrating you
could feel the kind of the compression
the the sound
investigators found 23 guns and rifles
in paddocks sweet along with two tripods
and thousands of rounds of ammunition
potential bomb-making chemicals were in
his car during the shooting many concert
goers were trapped by the fencing around
the wide open venue few places were safe
from paddocks high vantage point more
than 500 yards away I have worked here
for 30 years and I have never seen that
many ambulances that I saw last night
this shooting now involves four separate
crime scenes not just paddocks hotel
suite and the concert venue but also two
of paddocks homes
he lived in a retirement community in
the town of Mesquite outside Las Vegas
and also owned property in Reno alright
John thank you so much